now this is lovely I told you some of my
favorite objects this solves a mystery
that you guys have lived since year
seven but you've never known why it's
just kind of been magic for you okay
make a little subheading which is
recurring decimals now back in your 7
you learned how to take a recurring
decimal like for example zero point
seven four seven four seven four and you
learned to express it as a fraction you
can actually use some fancy algebra to
do that okay but I think I'm much more
elegant a nice way to do it is through
what we've just shown here let me try
and help you understand limiting sums
they only apply to GPS I'll let you have
a think about why they don't apply to
AP's they only apply to GPS which means
I'm suggesting that this is a GP that's
a GP it doesn't look like a GP it
doesn't look like one because
everything's been added up right it's
like a whole bunch of terms and they've
all been collapsed so what I want you to
do is help me tease it back out and show
me where the pieces come from okay
so what I'm suggesting is this is made
up of something plus something plus
something plus something and you get
smaller by a collar ratio each time okay
so for instance see if you have a look
at these two digits here right 0.74 what
is that as a fraction 0.74 it's 74 over
a hundred year seventy four hundredths
well that's the first piece if you have
a look at the next bit zero point zero
zero seven four what that is a fraction
that's 74 over just be careful right
it's actually ten thousand is it's a
hundred times smaller than this guy yeah
and if you go to this last one here no
surprises it's 74 over not 100 or 10,000
but a million
so there's the GP right but I know what
a GP is equal to if I can work out all
these pieces now I want you to watch
look carefully at what happens right did
you notice you've got some cancelling
happening because of this guy here do
you see that if this ratio is between
naught and one I should between negative
1 & 1 then that guy there that fractions
always going to go to 0 like we noticed
here it always goes to 0 okay so if that
part always goes to 0 what happens to
this whole bracket up here if this
always goes to 0 then that always goes
to 1 minus 0 do you see that which is
just 1 okay so therefore instead of a
outside of 1 minus R to the N on 1 minus
R you get a times 1 over 1 minus R but
that's just that's nothing right so this
is a over 1 minus R if there's a
limiting song so have a look at what
happens tell me what a is 74 over 100
there is / 1 - okay look carefully
what's the common ratio it's 1 over 100
every time it's getting a hundred times
smaller 1 over a hundred mmm
that looks a bit gross you can do
something with that right one minus a
hundredth that's going to be how many
hundredths
that'll be ninety-nine hundredths but
look I've got hundreds here I've got
hundredths here so just like you learnt
four years ago 74 or 99 is the fraction
that gives you this recurring decimal we
couldn't tell you back then about
geometric progressions because you were
throwing your books at us okay but now
you know that there are such objects as
the series that go on forever despite
going on forever you can express them in
a finite way and this formula oh man I
keep doing this this formula here is
what gives us that result okay
so in summary when you've got a GP and
when it's ratio is making numbers
smaller rather than making them bigger
even if it doesn't really so suppose the
ratio is this right 99 over 100 every
time you multiply 99 over 100 by itself
it gets smaller doesn't it a little bit
but it gets smaller the thing about
doing things an infinite number of times
is that even if it's super slow this
takes forever to get small guess what
I've got forever so it will also tend
toward zero okay one last thing you
don't have to do this it's just optional
I want to illustrate for you or
illustrate for you how this can be true
because that's weird that's weird
infinite on this is one okay you guys
know what the unit circle is right you
know if unit circle is this is clearly
not a unit circle this is a unit square
one times one okay some of you seen this
before which is fine if you took your
unit square and you divided it right
down the middle
what would the area be of this rectangle
over here that area is is 1/2 times one
yeah so far so good
okay now if I took the rectangle that
was left over and sliced it down the
middle
what would its area be
it's a half times a half which is a
quarter right they can keep doing this I
can go half here a quarter here that's
an eight yeah and there's a sixteenth
and 1 over 32 and 1 over 64 and I can go
forever if I did go forever how much of
this square will I come off and the
answer is I will cover the whole square
which has an area of 1 times 1 just like
you found ok